he was once called the world's smallest
cowboy and now you could say he has one
big story to tell as our david charn
shows us at 3 foot 10 kevin brown says
other people and his height never stood
in the way of his dream to getting into
show business i've had a hard life
but i've enjoyed all of it at 64 years
old and three feet 10 inches kevin brown
talks about his past not in years but in
feet as i got into high school it was
like three foot at an early age brown
learned his pituitary gland the one
regulating growth wasn't functioning
properly always been a positive person
you know no negativity in me it didn't
matter he heard the stage calling i
reached 3 foot 8 when i joined the
circus stints in tours from the u.s to
canada brought him back to las vegas in
the late 70s he was known as the world's
smallest cowboy pictured here in the
newspaper on a horse because i'm no
different than anybody else i i don't
owe anybody i don't lie i don't steal
telling us his story on this windy day
i've been wanting to do this for years
while throwing in a bit of humor i
considered about the cheapest date
around at 50 pounds he doesn't eat much
and finding adult clothes his size isn't
easy i get stared out a lot and it
bothers them it doesn't bother me and
when you got kids going by and they said
oh look at that
some are rude some are really cool the
cool ones he says even stop and take a
picture some think he's a child in
disguise i don't mind i take pictures
with kids other folks
the deep ink on his arms tells a
different story bowing out from the neon
lights becoming a different leading man
i said okay
i can't be a star
and
you know uh and raise a family with five
children brown is now a grandfather to
nine sometimes on halloween when i took
my kids trick-or-treat
i go to the door before
before they do
um the kid opens the door and screamed
and here comes the parents in the back
it was really cool now working different
jobs like at a garage i was blessed all
through my life
i have no enemies you can't help but
smile when he tells you stories like
this
i'm pulling into town and he just
trapped him zooming up and everything i
even thought it was a runaway truck
because he didn't even see me
after those days in showbiz the world is
certainly now seeing him i'm david
charns live local now